I just really quick Vince in that seven
spot is the nets and one week ago we
brought to you all of the guys that
they're missing and now it's gone from
seven players to eight because one of
the players they hoped could fill in
Michael Beasley literally just tested
positive for Kovac 19 never made his way
into the bubble and instead of Michael
Beasley they're gonna be relying very
heavily on the man the myth the legend
Jamal Crawford who I know that NBA fans
were crying for and Vince what is it
like that Jamal Crawford is back in the
league for you because you've seen a lot
of guys come and go he carry yeah he's
carried he's carrying the torch for the
whole school but this is a gifted score
a guy who to score anywhere on the floor
a tough guard for them when they need a
bucket you can give him the ball and get
out of the way and make plays I think
Beasley that's that's gonna hurt them
his ability to score in in a lot of ways
and you know now you plant you in the
plane a lot of small ball which is
popular but on the defensive side it's
gonna be a big gap with with Beasley out
there can we make a trade can we trade
teams in this bubble can we get like
seconds in here and let Brooklyn go get
like we make a trade like can we move
Jamal Crawford to the ball let that be
the way he'd go out the way he came in
and we might another team here because
Brooklyn ain't got ain't got no buy on
the roster no more and he probably
they're their feature player as far as
he'll be the go-to for sure I'm gonna
disagree listen I think Karis levert is
gonna absolutely put on a show
what do you heard you said that earlier
first you got no choice you heard it
here first
listen guys because there's no home
court advantage and they're playing in
the ballroom Brooklyn will advance to
the second round you heard it here first
okay big fella okay whoever they planned
as they plan in the dead ballroom they
plan
[Music]
either the top two seeds with walls
right next check what it gonna be
smaller you can go like that and touch
the world they they're making it to the
second round
watch cuz cuz you know what I'm saying
you can feel no clear no no no listen
with no clear cut home court advantage
emotions are going to be low and
everybody knows that they don't have
certain guys d wait Vince
Candice you know that's the toughest
team to play a team that you're not up
up for Jack alright maybe playing the
Raptors and I I think Shaq well you came
on with that sixth grade first day of
school polo on I said
[Laughter]